parliament will vote on the invest  eu program 400 billion euros of new  investments to support small and medium  businesses  and boost research innovation and  sustainable infrastructure  eu for health is a 5.1 billion euro  program that will help fix weaknesses in  our health care systems laid bare by the  pandemic  meps will vote on the plan which will  improve resilience for future crises  and promote research disease prevention  and healthy lifestyles  not all countries are as ambitious as  the eu in reducing carbon pollution  parliaments is set to call for a levy on  carbon heavy imports like steel and  cement  which don't meet eu environmental  standards  companies which trade in the eu should  be held responsible for any  environmental damage or human rights  abuses linked to their businesses  meps are set to call for new rules  obliging corporations to carry out due  diligence  and giving victims the right to legal  [Music]  recourse